travis barker is getting a little rest
and relaxation with wife kourtney
kardashian days after the blink 182
rocker was hospitalized for pancreatitis
we're just you know living our best
lives over the july 4th weekend court
documented the kardashian barker family
hitting the beach there's travis foot on
the gas as they catch some scenic views
driving along the coast in a vintage
orange truck with the top down court and
her kids penelope and rain all look
carefree with their hair blowing in the
wind
this family outing comes just days after
travis faced a life-threatening health
scare at the time a source told e.t
travis was sick and had intense pain in
his abdomen which made the couple
immediately call 9-1-1 we're told the
43-year-old reality star rushed travis
to a nearby hospital before he was
transported by ambulance to l.a cedar
sinai at that point doctors said travis
was suffering with pancreatitis a
condition that causes the pancreas to
get red and swell thankfully travis has
since been discharged on saturday he
spoke out for the first time explaining
to his followers how the scary ordeal
all went down travis took to his
instagram story saying he felt
excruciating pain before an endoscopy
exam quote i had a very small polyp
removed right in the very sensitive area
usually handled by specialists which
unfortunately damaged a critical
pancreatic drainage tube this resulted
in severe life-threatening pancreatitis
and courtney it's clear she's keeping
her vow to stick by travis's side
through sickness and health
[Music]
travis and courtney tied the knot in
italy back in may and before that the
pair started their journey to baby which
played out on season one of the
kardashians we did all these healthy
things and we made love and we made a
baby so now that we feel really healthy
we are going to
try naturally and take a big break from
ivf well whatever your journey around
courtney we support you and literally
and the family's support hasn't stopped
yes always this is my support group
travis's daughter alabama and atiana
both spoke out during their dad's
hospitalization thanking fans for the
outpouring of prayers and love
then there's courtney's mom kris jenner
and her boyfriend corey gamble who sent
travis a stunning bouquet of orange get
well soon flowers we love travis
[Music]